Hey guys Julia here for DNews
In 1964, a landmark report U.S. Surgeon General
Luther Terry made the case for the link between
smoking and cancer and heart disease.
In the years since, there the evidence pile
against smoking has only gotten larger.
There’s a more than a few ways smoking harms
the body, but let’s just focus on a few
certain compounds.
Smoking is lethal in a few ways.
In those early studies I mentioned, researchers
found that cigarette smoke causes ciliostasis.
Which is when those little hairs lining your
airways die.
Without those hairs, your body has a hard
time filtering out bad things, like cigarette
smoke.
Smoke isn't just one thing, it's a combination
of particles that result when you burn cigarettes.
As the more you smoke, the more smoke gets
in your lungs and the more likely tumors will
form due to the damaging particles.
As you know, tobacco smoke has lot of carcinogens.
According to a study published in the journal
Molecular Cancer Research there’s over 60
compounds known to cause cancer.
Compounds like polycyclic aromatic hydrocarbons
(PAH).
Which are formed when things like oil, gas,
and yup, tobacco are burned.
They can even form if you char things like
steak.
And once those compounds get past the dead
cilia, they find their way to vulnerable parts
of your lungs.
Some of these PAHs lead to chronic inflammation
of the lung, a condition which raises the
risk of cancer[1].
Some of these chemicals trigger mutations
when they bind to the DNA.
The compounds get stuck, forming what’s
called an adduct that makes it really hard
for the DNA to replicate, which can potentially
lead to mutations.
When this does happen, one of the most significant
mutations occurs in a protein called p53[2].
The protein handles a lot of cell regulation,
and its function depends on a variety of factors,
but often it’s a tumor suppressor.
When this protein experiences a mutation,
that function gets switched off, allowing
tumors in the lungs to grow and spread.
One study published in the journal Clinical
Cancer Research found that a mutation in p53
was a maker of poor cancer prognosis.
And polycyclic aromatic hydrocarbons aren’t
linked with just cancer, but research published
in the journal The FASEB Journal, found that
these compounds can trigger heart disease
too[3].
Basically these compounds cause an overproduction
of certain fatty acids in endothelial cells,
the cells that line your blood vessels, which
causes them to die.
So yeah, smoking literally kills your blood
vessels.
Smoking also increases the risk of heart disease
by narrowing the blood vessels and increasing
the formation of clotting plaque, which can
lead to deadly heart attacks.
In fact it counts for 33% of all heart disease
related deaths in the US.
Still don’t believe smoking hurts?
Well it can literally turn your lungs black.
two recent studies confirm that yup.
Smoking is deadly.
The smoking gun?
Carbon nanoparticles.
Similar to black lung syndrome, when coal
miners inhaled coal dust, these particles
from cigarettes get stuck in the lung and
wreak havoc.
In smokers the particles can build up and
lead to severe emphysema.
A nasty and potentially fatal condition that
makes it harder to breathe.
The particles come from material that hasn’t
burned up all the way, which in this case
is the tobacco itself.
They’re small, around 30 and 40 nanometers
in size; about half the width of a human hair.
But over time these nanoparticles build up
and can do some serious damage.
The first study published in the journal eLife,
found that they are so small that once they
get into the dendritic cells they can break
apart DNA.
So yeah, there’s lots of ways cigarette
smoke causes cellular damage through variety
of molecular mechanisms.
With all this scientific evidence against
it, I’m baffled why so many people still
smoke.
But hey it’s a comforting habit for some,
and as we've discussed before, an addicting
one too.
Thanks nicotine.
But there’s some good news.
Studies show that some of the effects might
be reversible… except those particles.
You’re stuck with those.
So the evidence is overwhelming.
You should probably quit smoking now.
Plus it’s just gross.